I think Trump in lots of ways is a
refreshing reminder that the guy that's
in the white house is another human
being and that bringing that power back
to human scale is an important part of
what needs to be done to correct the
insanity that's been going on in the
post-war era Luis Rossetto is the
co-founder of Wired magazine and the co
recipient of the very first Lanny
Friedlander prize from reason it honors
an individual or group has created a
publication medium or distribution
platform that vastly expand human
freedom in 1971 while an undergraduate
at Columbia University he co-authored a
story in The New York Times magazine
titled the new right credo
libertarianism liberalism conservativism
and leftist radicalism are all bankrupt
philosophies he wrote refugees from the
old right the old left and the new left
are organizing independently under the
banner of libertarianism Rosetta's
newest project is a novel called change
is good a story from the heroic era of
the internet which he and designer Erik
Spiekermann launched on Kickstarter the
project raised nearly two hundred
thousand dollars and is going out to
backers now Louis thanks for talking
here what's the plot of change is good
it's a novel right it's an easy question
to start with there were six characters
each of them have their own stories I
suppose for this for you at this moment
the most interesting thing about the
book is the focus on that time we're
talking the book is set in the in the
1990s and the 1990s were this pivotal
moment in world history where well cast
your mind back was a period of
unbelievable optimism so there's a Cold
War is over the Internet is taking off
is becoming a mass medium the Cold War
economy is doing great the cold war ends
the beginning of the 90s
the internet takes off with the arrival
of the web the period it's this there's
drugs ecstasy the rave culture multiple
different levels there are massive
changes going on that are affecting all
aspects of our life and so the 90s is
its pivotal moment where there's this
burst of optimism young people are
arriving in this new space of the
Internet the web
digital technologies in general and
there's a sense that the future is
utterly malleable for the first time in
a long time after the after the Cold War
the the fear and anxiety of the Cold War
now there's this open Running Room it's
the end of history literally Fukuyama
says so and now anything's possible any
weird crazy idea that you have is no
longer bound by normal restrictions like
finance or law or even physical bounds
it is incredibly hard to go back to
those early days of even pre-internet
culture but even a o/l American online
had the walled garden where you could
people were anonymous you you had you
know fake names that you would use and
talk about anything using that groups
you could reproduce things cheaply DVD
players were $7 or whatever I mean
companies had zero income had billion
dollar valuations companies were more
valuable than General Motors that that
were selling in the tens of millions of
dollars and it had Bill Clinton saying
the era of big government is over there
were all sorts of things happening in
society at that moment in all levels of
society that were pointing toward a
millennial future that was going to be
almost utopian and there were people
involved in the 90s that were making
that happen the Gen Xers of that time
were adventurers and revolutionaries
honestly looking to travel to a new land
west of California and bring back fresh
kill for the human race and that was a
future and they were actively out there
making that new future so that's what
heroic I mean in the sense that people
felt like they could do heroic
undertakings and that you you could do
whatever if you could dream it you could
do it I mean it's kind of like Walt
Disney on ecstasy it's heroic when you
do it in the face of danger and
opposition which you also have at the
same time because you're moving like the
elite like the Lewis and Clark into this
new territory that was undefined
that was unmapped and that was full of
danger in lots of ways any company could
go under any moment any weirdness could
be popping out of the things that you're
discovering and so change is good is
about six characters exploring this new
realm like Lewis and Clark going out
into this uncharted territory and
helping to discover what that was all
about and in fact also helping to create
our future it takes place in 1998 which
is another pivotal moment within a
pivotal moment because for most of the
90s there was a suspension Airy sense of
the future looking incredibly wonderful
and then there was a ton of money that
flowed into that into the sector in 1998
and that became what be what was the
digital revolution became the dot-com
bubble and what was utopian became greed
and so I'm trying to examine that
particular tipping point between the
moment when people had fire in their
eyes and wanted to change the world and
and they ended up being I guess
perverted in the kind of way into or
seduced into pursuing the pure joy of
making a lot of money I hope one day to
experience that myself
what if that was the heroic age of the
Internet what what do you how would you
characterize the internet now or America
now it does not seem to be for mean the
internet does not seem to be
particularly heroic does it I think the
Internet just become part of our life
it's gone from a cult to the culture and
it's just everything that's normal
today is connected as we said it would
be to digital call do digital
technologies and the networks themselves
I think you have to look to other places
to see where this edge is today and in
many ways what James is doing is is
looking for that edgy at neo life and so
a lot of it is and it's kind of
interesting because baby boomers
obviously also took charge in the 90s I
mean when Bill Bill Clinton was the
first baby boomer president 92 and baby
boomers have long been accused of being
solipsistic and and weird-looking but
hardly true yeah but also now literally
that's happening right because we're
looking at our own bodies and changing
them in ways that were unimaginable what
a few years there's a new generation
it's that's pursuing this this new
adventure and there are new adventures
out there I think the Internet's become
the background there are there are still
an edge there are still edges all over
the place the genetic revolution is one
of them space is another transportation
is another one I mean there are
explorations to be had all over the
place the kind of incredible fervor that
you saw with the with the arrival of the
internet that affected everything
simultaneous all over simultaneously all
over the planet that kind of change is
unlikely to happen in the same broad way
that it did then instead you have a
bunch of little or smaller changes that
are erupting and that will become their
own major thing but they're just lots of
them happening out there you also talk
about the book and this brings us to
Erik Spiekermann but it's a revolution
in printing what is unique about the
printing process and and why the
attention to that
detail why make a bunch of atoms put
together a bunch of atoms to to
experience this story instead of just
putting that digitally it's a very it's
a very good question because in DM you
also want to create another experience
there's a story which is an abstraction
in lots of ways and then there's a
physical object of the book and in lots
of ways books have become devalued as
they migrated into the doodle digital
domain domain and the book the book
itself as an object has become degraded
it's a it's a mass object that is not
special that doesn't deliver a great
experience the inks are not great the
papers not great the bindings aren't
great
nothing about it is special and so we
said why don't we make a real but
nevertheless it's still the best way to
read things I mean we like to read
things on screen but still paper offers
the best way to read and so why don't we
make an a special experience the best
experience we can make in the 21st
century for reading itself that required
Eric to begin an exploration of printing
itself and he rediscovered an old way of
printing letterpressed instead of the
more normal way everything is printed
today which is offset letterpress is
actually an image pressed into a piece
of paper and it's it's something that
got lost in the mass in mass marketing
because it just couldn't make the
transition to the new technologies for
producing print and what Eric has done
is reinvented a way of producing plates
for letterpress which enable you to use
all the digital tools for publication
but it but apply them to this classic
technology of letterpress and
so he created tools to make the plates
that go on the press and why and this
particular book changes good is among
the very first to use his technology
it's the first one that he's designing
and publishing himself and it's just a
special experience to read crisp type
impressed in the paper where its words
actually you actually have a physical
impression in the paper which adds a
third dimension to the experience of
weeding which we don't really know about
anymore because everything we get is
offset which is completely flat so you
have the experience of the impression of
the paper an impression of the of the
type on the paper and then you also a
black ink which you never get with
offset offset is by definition variants
of gray where this ink that's pressed
into the paper is actually black and so
altogether
the experience of reading change is good
is basically state of the art for the
21st century and then you also have
thrown in a Spotify soundtrack also
because we can yes and so if you look at
the very beginning of the book there's a
link to Spotify which enables you to
listen to the soundtrack that we put
together which is like 10 hours of music
for listening to the book at your
leisure you know we've known each other
for about 20 years now or coming up on
20 years one of the things over the past
couple years that expen a maverick you
know at a time when during Wired you
were you know seen as suspiciously
libertarian and your proclivities and
whatnot you have surprised a lot of
people over the past couple years by
being a if not pro Trump Pro Donald
Trump you were enjoying his intervention
into politics into the political status
quo how do you feel about him after a
year in office and you know what is it
about him that piques your curiosity and
you know what is he bringing to the
stage that you think is
you know really vital I think for most
of my life my tendency has been to try
to diminish the the power of the state
in general and part of that is literal
power and part of is the power that's in
your head and the presidency is taken on
this otherworldly position in people's
minds that is beyond Pope hood it's this
figure of immense authority that you are
obliged to respect and that you and that
and that has all this and and and has
the because of the power of the United
States in general has the ability to
project it that power all over the
planet
I think Trump in lots of ways is a
refreshing reminder that the guy that's
in the White House is another human
being and the power of the state is way
too exalted and that bringing that power
back to human scale is an important part
of what needs to be done to correct the
insanity that's been going on in the
post-war era to where you have these
large institutions that control all
aspects of our lives so leaching respect
and authority out of the state it's kind
of a good thing on its on its own level
and maybe I'll just leave it at that
okay well we will leave it there we've
been talking with Luis Rosetta the
co-founder of wired and the novelist
behind change is good a story of the
heroic era of the Internet and a
revolution imprinting Louis thanks for
talking pleasure as always for reason
I'm Nick Gillespie
[Music]